[Applause]
Hank you've just been greeted by the
project for awesome donors who joined me
this weekend to watch AFC Wimbledon's
2-1 victory over Oxford United a
critical win because in order for
everyone's favorite third tier English
soccer team not to become a fourth tier
English soccer team they need to finish
in 20th or above and that wind took AFC
Wimbledon up to the dizzying heights of
18th but anyway my 27 hours in England
reminded me of something weird about
contemporary us life which is that we're
going through challenges that lots of
Americans don't even know exist right
like people get their news from such
wildly divergent sources that we don't
even hear the same stories let alone
agree on what they mean and so even if
something terrible happened say back in
October many people won't have heard
about it which means that some of you
are about to learn for the very first
time that the u.s. men's national team
did not qualify for the World Cup I know
right how is this even possible I mean
the United States is the richest nation
on earth and FIFA is famously bribable
what went wrong basically we lost to
Costa Rica twice and Mexico and Trinidad
and Tobago
but you know the old saying when God
closes a door how do you lose to
Trinidad and Tobago I think that's the
old saying okay but look the United
States was not the only country to fail
to qualify for the World Cup Italy won't
be there nor will the Netherlands or
Chile or Canada or China or New Zealand
or lots of other countries and for all
of us in those countries we have a
problem or possibly an opportunity who
do we root for and also is there any way
we can sell our support for charity of
course or possibly for our own
enrichment no for charity that's better
people of the 179 nations that did not
qualify for the World Cup we need to
band together as one bad at football
world and find one or possibly a few
countries to root for and I'm talking
about going all in jerseys face paint
learning some chants weeping for joy and
then sorrow and then joy and then
finally sorrow the obvious strategy
would just be to auction off our love
some nerdfighters and I did this back in
2014 and raised over $10,000 for sarcoma
research and that might still be the
best way to go about it but the big down
was that of course the rich countries
ended up donating the most which kind of
took some of the fun out of it so if you
have any ideas on how to raise money
while deciding who to root for please
leave them in comments and if you don't
have any ideas please read the comments
and vote for your favorite ideas you
know who made it to the World Cup by the
way Iceland which has a population
smaller than that of Wichita Kansas also
Costa Rica which just passed the US and
life expectancy and also obviously in
soccer ability but I'm on a tangent the
important thing here is that those of us
without a rooting interest in the World
Cup need to find one because otherwise
we will be forced to gaze into the
yawning abyss of meaninglessness I'm not
totally kidding about that by the way
like I know a lot of you will say that
you don't care about soccer and then
it's just people trying to get a
spherical object into a net without
using their hands which is like the
stupidest human activity imaginable and
I get that but the central mistake of
your reasoning is that football is not
actually about feet or balls it's about
community football matters because we
share it and we need to find big
endeavors to share across Geographic and
cultural divides because they remind us
that we are truly all in this together
of course sport isn't the only way to
achieve that feeling but I think
achieving it in sport does help us feel
it elsewhere so I'm not kidding I want
to find a team to root for in the World
Cup we need to care about stuff caring
is so underrated as Pope John Paul the
second footed of all the unimportant
things football is the most important
Hank I'll see you on Friday